It's 8 p.m. on Saturday.
Officers Rainer Fuchs and Alexander Schwarzer
are starting their shift.
Their beat is Cologne's so-called party mile,
chasing down speeders - mostly young men with
fast cars who race through the city.
Many street races start like this:
"Waiting at a traffic light they'll look at
each other and say: Hey, check it out - you're
low, big and broad.
But I'm even lower and bigger and have way
more under the hood.
So let's go!"
After just 10 minutes, they spot something.
"That one there"
"The Audi."
"Slow down a bit.
Otherwise you'll give yourself away."
"As you heard just now he was revving his
car pretty loudly."
"Let's pull him over."
The driver, a young man, fits the street racer
profile, most of whom are male between 18
and 27.
Street racers tune their cars.
Often without permits.
And many of the changes are illegal.
What's been changed?
"What it says on the registration."
"What does it say?"
There are a number of ways to tune a car:
engine, suspension, exhaust.
The police inspect the car on site.
They know what to look for.
"You're allowed 73 according to vehicle registration,
but you're at 80 with this.
That's too much."
"Fact is, his exhaust has been tinkered with.
The operating license is expired.
And the car's performance has been enhanced,
which has been registered, but the inspection
authority should have another look."
The car gets confiscated for the weekend.
On Monday, it will go to inspection for a
technical review.
There will likely be a fine or a warning,
but that hardly scares off most racers.
"It's about showing off, to improve their
standing - their social status."
"They probably think that they're great drivers.
But unfortunately they're often not.
Which is also why we keep seeing these terrible
accidents."
One fatal incident happened on Cologne's Auenweg.
An illegal race resulted in one of the drivers
losing control of the car and slamming into
a cyclist.
She died of her injuries.
The victim was 19 years old.
The driver was convicted of involuntary manslaughter.
"In the wake of the accident we learned just
how much street racing has spread into the
city, and how dangerous it is."
Cologne's street racing taskforce was set
up in 2015.
Come 11 p.m., it's primetime for them.
More alcohol, and more testosterone means
more racers coming their way.
And here's another suspect.
"Another modified car.
You can see the upgraded exhaust, different
doors.
The car's moving pretty quickly."
What really stands out though are the struts.
But the driver refuses to hand over his keys.
"You can either follow orders by choice or
by force.
Then they'll be another car here, and another
- and we'll take your car in the end, believe
me.
I need you car keys, please."
"No, you're not getting them."
"Then we'll tow the car."
The taskforce says any car that's been tuned
beyond what's allowed is a potential racer
and danger to others.
Which is why night after night, the officers'
search continues.